Ready when you are.
Sweet.
One... two… three
I just wanna be. You just wanna be.  We just wanna be.
I don’t wanna be. You don’t wanna be. We don’t wanna be told what to do.
No I won’t cut my hair. And I’ll wear whatever. I like it when I get to be myself.
I just wanna be. You just wanna be.  We just wanna be.
I don’t wanna be. You don’t wanna be. We don’t wanna be told what to do.
And I try my best to do good in the neighborhood.
I smile real nice and I strive to tell the truth.
I just wanna be. You just wanna be.  We just wanna be.
I don’t wanna be. You don’t wanna be. We don’t wanna be told what to do.
I am gonna be who I wanna be. My autonomy.
I just wanna be. You just wanna be.  We just wanna be.
My friends are quality, not quantity.